in the last video you saw the basic beam
search algorithm in this video you learn
some little changes that make it work
even better length normalization is a
small change to the beam search
algorithm that can help you get much
better results here's what it is we
talked about beam search as maximizing
this probability and this product here
is just expressing the observation that
P of y1 up to Y T Y given X can be
expressed as P of y 1 given X times P of
Y 2 given X and y1 x dot dot up to I
guess p r y py given X and y1 up to Y T
y -1 but then maybe this notation is a
bit more scary and more intimidating
than it needs to be but this is that
probability proper the probabilities
that you've seen previously now if
you're implementing these these
probabilities are all numbers less than
1 in fact often they are much less than
1 and multiplying a lot of numbers less
than 1 result in a tiny tiny tiny number
which can result in numerical underflow
meaning that is too small for the
floating-point representation in your
computer to store accurately so in
practice instead of maximizing this
product we will take logs and if you
insert a lot there then the log of a
product becomes a sum of a log and
maximizing this sum of long
probabilities should give you the same
result in terms of selecting the most
likely sentence Y so by taking logs you
end up with a more numerically stable
algorithm that is less prone to rounding
errors numerical rounding errors or to
really numerical underflow and
because the log function that's the
logarithmic function there's a strictly
monotonically increasing function
maximizing P of Y and because the
logarithmic function here's the log
function is a strictly monotonically
increasing function we know that
maximizing log P of Y given X should
give you the same result as maximizing P
of Y given X as in the same value of y
that maximizes this should also maximize
that so in most implementations you keep
track of the sum of logs of the
probabilities rather than the product of
the problem what sees now there's one
other change to this objective function
that makes the machine translation
algorithm work even better which is that
if you refer to this original objective
up here if you have a very long sentence
the probability that sentence is going
to be low because you're multiplying as
many terms here lots of numbers are less
than 1 to estimate the probability of
that sentence and so if you multiply law
the numbers are less than 1 together you
just tend to end up with a smaller
probability and so this objective
function has a undesirable effect that
it may be unnaturally tends to prefer
very short translations tests prefer
very short outputs because the
probability of a short sentence is
determined just by multiplying fewer of
these numbers are less than 1 and so the
product will just be not quite as small
and by the way the same thing is true
for this the log of a probability is
always less than or equal to 1 you're
actually in this range of the log so the
more terms you have together the more
negative this thing becomes so there's
one other change the algorithm that
makes it work better which is instead of
using this as the objective you're
trying to
maximize one thing you could do is
normalize this by the number of words in
your translation and so this takes the
average of the log of the probability of
each word now and this and this
significantly reduces the penalty for
outputting longer translations and in
practice as a heuristic instead of
dividing by T why but the number of
words in the output sentence sometimes
you used a softer approach where you
have T Y to the power of alpha where
maybe alpha is equal to 0.7 so if alpha
was equal to 1 then Y a completely
normalizing by length if alpha was equal
to zero then well T Y to the 0 would be
1 then you're just not normalizing at
all and this is somewhere in between for
normalization and no normalization and
alpha is another parameter or hyper form
to the algorithm that you can tuned to
try to get the best results and have
them it using alpha this way this is a
heuristic or this is a hack there isn't
a great theoretical justification for it
but people found this works well people
found that works well in practice so
many groups will do this and you can try
out different values of how fair until
and then see which one gives you the
best result so just to wrap up how you
run beam search as you run beam search
you see a lot of sentences with length
equal 1 long sentences of length equal
to law sentence of thank you goes 3 and
so on and maybe you run beam search for
30 steps you'll consider I'll put
sentences up to length 30 let's say and
so would beam with a 3 you were keeping
you would be keeping track of the top 3
possibilities for each of these possible
sentence lengths 1 2 3 4 and so on up to
30 then you would look at all the output
sentences and
Skol them against this score and so you
can take your top sentences and just
compute this objective function on the
sentences that you have seen through the
beam search process and then finally of
all these sentences that you evaluate
this way you'll pick the one that
achieves the highest value on this sum
normalize law probability objective
sometimes it's called a normalize log
likelihood objective and then that would
be the final translation your output so
that's how you implement beam search and
you get to play this yourself in this
week's programming exercise finally a
few implementational details how do you
choose the beam with be the larger B is
the more possibilities are considering
and does the better the sentence you
probably find but the larger beers the
more computationally expensive your
algorithm is because you're also keeping
a lot more possibilities around so
finally let's just wrap up with some
thoughts on how to choose the beam with
B so here are the pros and cons of
setting B to be very large versus very
small if the beam wave is very large
then you consider a lot of possibilities
and so you tend to get a better result
because you're concerned a lot of
different options but it will be slower
and the memory requirements will also
grow it'll also be computationally
slower whereas if you use a very small
beam width then you get the worst result
because you're just keeping less
possibilities in mind as the algorithm
is running but you get a result faster
and the memory requirements will also be
lower so in the previous video we use in
our running example of beam width of 3
so we're keeping three possibilities in
mind in practice that is on the small
side in production systems it's not
uncommon to see it being with maybe
around 10
and I think being worth of a hundred we
consider very large for a production
system depending on the application but
for research systems where people want
to squeeze out every last drop in
performance in order to publish a paper
in the best possible result it's not
uncommon to see people use B oneself or
a thousand or three thousand but this is
very application as well as domain
dependent so I would say try out a
variety of values of B and see what
works for your application but when B
gets very large there is often
diminishing returns so for many
applications I would expect to see a
huge gain as you go from being off of
one which may seem greedy search to
three to maybe ten but the gains as you
go from a thousand to three thousand and
be with might not be as big and for
those of you that have taken maybe a lot
of computer science courses before if
you're familiar with computer science
search algorithms like BFS breadth-first
search or DFS deficit the way to think
about beam search is that unlike those
other algorithms which you may have
learned about in computer science
algorithms course and don't worry about
it if you've not heard of these
algorithms but if you've heard of
professor to therefore search then
unlike those algorithms which are exact
search algorithms beam so she runs much
faster but does not guarantee to find
the exact maximum for this automatically
you like to find if you haven't heard a
breadth-first search your deck for
search don't worry about it it's not
important for our purposes but if you
have this is how beam search relates to
those algorithms so that's it the beam
search which is a widely used algorithm
in many production systems there are
many commercial systems now in the third
course in this sequence of courses on
deep learning we talk a lot about error
analysis it turns out one of the most
useful tools I've found is similar to
error analysis on beam search so you
sometimes wonder should I increase my
beam width is my beam working well
enough and there's some simple things
you can
to give you guidance on whether you need
to work on improving your search
algorithm let's talk about that in the
next video